Okay, so we got a hundred-twenty peasants versus one...
Rocky Balboa!
Let's see what happens. I don't know how I think you're gonna-
*laughing* Well shit, you didn't even get to one
bOaT
dOG
I think I have an erection *giggle*
*while laughing* I think I have a tumor
I think I have cancer
I think I have...
*giggling* a pet named Steve
*Laughing*
Bob: Alright
Wade: I've never seen this-
Mark, Bob, and Wade: *a mix of woahs and oh my god*
*small scream by Mark* Wade: Oh!
*Everyone laughs*
Where'd I come from where'd I go where the fuck did the video go?
Oh my name! Inomina fuck
Uh- uh
They're gonna hug it out they're a peaceful bunch
GOD TAOB
*inaudible sounds from wade bob and mark*
Wade: COME ON
I bet you're gonna d- well, that's one down,
Two, woop woop woop, woop! woop!
*music*
Your range does nothing when they hump you from either side.
Boink! Oh my God, you're angry!
Boop boop bo-*giggle*hoop boop boop boop
*bapbapbapbapbapbapbapbap*
O-hoh give me a big kiss!
Mmuah-haha
How 'bout the other drawer?
Oh No! It is Say-tan!
Well... goodbye then *giggle*
Heh- oh ho- Goodness gracious!
Oh ho ho-kay!
Oh-ho!
Great!
Wonderful!
Aawesome. They *giggle* hey did it!  They're so happy.
Oh! Oh Shit!-- Mark: wow --Jack!
AAAAAH HAHA! *markimoo laughs*
Oh god, my oosers need pumpage
Neh-euh-euh-euh
I'm pumping as hard as I can!
You're gonna get both cannons now. Clown: No, no, please oh, God aaaaaaaah
Mark: Yep, that's what you deserve.
Wade: climb up in here and get those bear traps all...
go get the ones that are over to the left.
Mark: you got it.
come on...
Yeah I remember like- oops
I remember like exploring the entirety of the map and-and I-I couldn't really find this g-
AAAAAH!!
Fucking hell! Good god!
Mark: Oh, you sack of shit.
*Wade laughs*
I actually believed you!
Oh my God oh my- oh my god *giggle*
Oh my go *laugh* hod o-ho no!
They're just humping that dead one!
Oh my god!
Oh, good lord.
This is inappropriate.
*High pitched boat dog*
*laughing* I think I swallowed a penis
I think I swallowed a my pet named Steve!
I'm sorry.
I- this is NOT FUNNY.
Oh- you're not gonna- oh fuck
God dammit
You're not gonna trick me. I'm gonna trick me. I'm the only one that trick me trick do!
That's eh- promising-
Oh-ho-ho god! Oh god! *laughing*
*Laughs even more*
Oh-ho my god *still laughing*
You like this dramatic music playing as we watch this guy bap his dick around back and forth oh, so sensually
Ohp up
He dead now
Hello, everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to the Rake multiplayer.
We got w-  Why did you do tha-
*Laughing*
You guys don't know how funny that looked on my screen...
*more laughing*
J-fred: Okay. Final answer- Mark: Yeah.
Matt: It was wrong.
Mark: WHAT?!?!
WHAT WAS IT-
AAHH! GOD DAMMIT!
Matt: I wasn't- Was I not supposed to shock him?
*Mark screaming*
What was i- What was it??
J-Fred: I don't know, they never told me!
Matt: You- you pointed at the camera!
Mark: Yeah!
Matt: That- how'd that ge- That was getting worse!
Mark: OOW
You like that? Muah! How about a little bit o' that, on the tip of your giant nose?
Oh!
Float like a butterfly, kiss like a bee! Muah
What's it like to be gay?
What's it like to be a girl?
*laughing* What's it like to be a pet named Steve?
*Laughing*
*Slowed down Boat Dog*
Wade: He's after whoever's on the roof, that's why he's broken.
Mark: YEAHH! He's after me!  Bob: O-oh my God!
I'm shooting at 'er now!
Little bitch!
Bob: How close do you think we can get, Wade?
Don't- don't get too close. I want to kill him. Oh wow
*Bob and Mark dying*
Thanks for watching.
All of the videos in this compilation are available in the description so check them out!
And if you'd like to see more in the future,
Please leave a like to let me know.
If you enjoyed this video,
and you'd like to see more on a daily basis, please subscribe today,
or if you're already subscribed share this video with a friend.
Thanks again for watching and I'll see you in the next video.
BYE BYEEEE!